what is going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch
an episode that i am very much concerned
will have to be blurred quite a bit
because of the fact that we uh being so
many yellow dollar bills on my main
concern is not even the yellow dollar
bill signs anymore it's more about just
making sure this doesn't get taken off
of youtube or age restricted or get it
community guidelines
those are the main real concerns right
now which is why we tend to have
sponsors on the boys so that way we can
not worry about the whole yellow dollar
bill signs but anyway the boys 3x6 we're
here
guys leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also uh leave your thoughts
below on the episode down below and
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode of the boyz is up
here on the channel full length of watch
alongs where you sync up with the time
code are available over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects go ahead
check out everything else we got to
offer over there as well also thank you
tim and prepper boys helping us add down
these highlights and thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction let's
get to it
together we can imagine a better world
imagine there's no heaven
yes
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
soldier boy
no it's impossible he died like 40 years
ago someone's cosplaying look at his
face
homelander looks so disturbed you want
to tell the world that soldier boy
hero of heroes is back from the [ __ ]
dead and blowing up midtown before me he
was fought his statue's in front of the
[ __ ] building ashley
yeah it's not fair homelander
why would he kill crimes encounters
i'm really glad to have you with me on
this one
we all deserve a friend like black noir
take out his chip or something
what a
man i badass benny's it's how we won
d-day you know we were wired to the
[ __ ] gills
we're here to help you find your way
well i could find them on my own
do you know what a gps is or
bluetooth or i mean the internet
you made those words out
[Laughter]
and all we ask in return
is that you add
one more name to the list
name the homeland
he's the new you
no one's the new me pal
but why him
let's just say you're not the only one
who wants payment
put together an orgy the biggest orgy
you've ever seen
why did the photo go to you
can't figure it out
something about being exposed maybe
[Laughter]
i want charges brought okay a train
persecuting blue hawk will only make
things worse this is a time for healing
i don't give a [ __ ]
i thought we got rid of the nazis around
here
nazism unequivocally
can we talk okay
this later i have a lot going on today
don't pull out your hair or hair my dear
my brother is paralyzed i want some
[ __ ] justice seriously
[Laughter]
let's not forget
you also murdered yeah that's right
you did not give a [ __ ] about all the
collateral you caused then
now all of a sudden you care
because it happened to you
go [ __ ] yourself
oh
yeah that's right
i said that
out
loud
you go ashley makes a good individual
point about a train we think crimson
countess was just the start we think
he's going after his whole team
including the war the good news is that
means we know where he's probably headed
next
the twins tnt to the closest
vermont oh [ __ ]
you go there and if soldier boy
does show up
you call me yeah
what should i tell the twins i don't
give a [ __ ] got it
invites into the herogasm for all i care
about the long face tiger what if it was
a mistake to take over vauden and they
all know i'm a fraud and what do you
care what a bunch of mud people think
science want them to
love me gutsy
[Music]
so why do you keep running head first
into the same brick wall it's because
deep down there's a part of you that is
still
human no
oh my god dirty shriveled anemic little
party that still mules
oh god
well then my boy you can finally be who
you were always meant to be a pure
nature yeah like marble oh at least he's
getting self-validation from himself
yeah would rather die than be soviet
slaves
afghanistan is ours and i'll stand by
our mujahideen brothers until the end
you know what else i'll do
vaught
i'll distract you
the twins
scream
i blacked out
when i came to the damage was done
i didn't mean to hurt those people hmm
but that won't happen again
right
only if they got it coming
always what you want to hear
my sister's a goddamn [ __ ] and uh tnt
right i'm a big fan of yours too
i always felt you got railroaded with
that starlight thing by the way you know
like what nowadays you can't even pay a
lady a compliment oh my god
anyway we are just so pleased you know
you could hear it in the background yep
you guys having a party
oh yes oh here we go
[Music]
oh my god he is desperate oh my god he
is so pathetic
who's joining us
they didn't tell you hey there
holy balls oh no
but there are 19 dead and dozens wounded
congresswoman newman what do you say to
the americans who are watching right now
and feeling scared yeah look it's
understanding kind of a nasty question
is that nasty they know when someone's
telling them facts and they know when
the media is lying to them my god it is
safe to go out period
yeah we're done here
nice
hey uh are you free for a little catch
up no
i'm a little slammed right now oh come
on
ten minutes won't kill you oh yeah yeah
everything she says she's so scared
don't blow her head up please where's
huey oh he's just camping with his dad
okay good oh great i thought he was
avoiding me or something you know cause
he was scared i was gonna pop his head
not gonna hurt you
or huey or your families
besides you'd lose
you're all alone i mean come on that
hashtag home light [ __ ] that looks like
you're in a hostage video
[Laughter]
let me your influence and i'll lend you
mine i can protect you from homelander
and in return you help me goose my
numbers
i can finally get my education reform
bill passed
because she's better annie
for my daughter
for a lot of daughters
girls get it done
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] homelander and [ __ ] vaught and this
whatever it takes crap i'm [ __ ]
done i'm not doing it anymore i'm going
to hear orgasm
hey keep this between us
really tough to take out america's
sweetheart
but not impossible
oh man
nice little tease
oh bad news
bad news bad news bad news
i'm so sorry
friendship
crap
his body is a masterpiece no
oh frenchy
this is my favorite
when sergey was 14 years old he dropped
the glass
his father told him to kneel in the
shards and not move until he said so ah
christ
he likes to be told what to do
and he loves to be punished when he's
bad
so
sherry no okay make one no don't do it
you'll kill both of them and when you
finish screaming crying i will kill you
too how do you know
oh
[ __ ]
come on can we go
yes oh yes
[ __ ] brutal
no
oh my god
oh my god
jesus christ
yes
[ __ ] yes
oh
shot i know
all i know is that if we didn't check
the burners three times a night soldier
boy would come back and kill the rest of
us oh my dude
oh golly it's back oh my god it's back
come in you are more than welcome to
party
party yeah the 70th anniversary of
hirogasm [ __ ] me
oh
you're not soup
i'm with her
for the [ __ ] party
yeah they're going all out
jeepers oh no
no
more frenchie
he's always wanted to see this he's
gonna be heartbroken
a poor frenchie
awesome props to that stunt guy when
soldier boy gets here it's going to be a
slaughter we have to get these people
out
oh oh no oh you're what's the fill alive
what
oh damn
[Laughter]
still a thing eh there's my thing
i founded it in 52.
oh yeah
oh no this is a bad luck man
you better go invisible
what is he doing
jesus oh
no what are you doing here nothing i'm
not doing anything why would you even
this octopus was sick why would you ask
homelander is gonna love this no no wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait please please please stop stop
stop no
oh
i hate your mouth i hate the way your
jaw pops when you chew and i hated every
second i spent holding that clammy head
i should have killed you and [ __ ] you
sorry oh jesus no no
no
you never apologized
for robin i'm sorry
it's [ __ ] up
seeing somebody that you love get
hurt like that
oh
homelander
is coming
the deep told me
when those two start fighting
this could be awesome television what
it's gonna be
the best episode yet of course
oh yep
you have to go no i need to stop
jesus christ all i want is to save you
you keep saying that but i don't need
you to save me right god forbid i help
you because i always have to be the weak
one oh dude
you killed my family
which one
oh come on man twins are up there
so you get homeland
but i can't get soldier boy
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite butcher now
move i'll come let you do it
it'll be suicide
here's noira's idea top to bottom he
gave you to the russians please
you i wouldn't take a [ __ ]
without vats say so
no oh no oh no
oh buddy
[Music]
you guys are always away at the right
time
oh
god jesus christ not right now there's a
psycho back there
oh
you heard a lot of people
you hurt my brother
whoa
oh my god adrian's really back your
heart buddy
oh
damn
that was unexpected
holy [ __ ]
yeah man
at least hide in the bushes
oh damn is that the end for him
wow i could see that being hit for him
man
[Laughter]
so long termite
what happened
you happened
bruh oh [ __ ] here we go
no
william we made a deal to fight till the
death
this is cheating
heels off
whoa
you're the only one that was nearly as
strong as me
buddy you think you look strong
you're wearing a cape
[ __ ] knock off
i'm the upgrade
yes here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
there
oh
[ __ ] come on butcher oh [ __ ] what have
you done
oh
god damn he's never really put up a
fight come on
yes
yes
[Music]
oh my god take that cape
oh
[ __ ]
oh this is sweet
yes oh you is in the fight
oh my god take him down
[Music]
whoa
get out of here no [ __ ] way
[Music]
come on soldier boy come on buddy
they were so close
no
no no no you were raised man
you were taught to survive
we cannot escape our own lives huh
i suppose no one can run that vest
damn that bruise they really put up a
fight
god damn that's wild man
it's a lot of dead soups i'm in
montpelier vermont
12 heroes and civilians are dead a lot
more are wounded oh she could
earn vaude are going to tell you that it
was the super villain and that they have
it handled
they don't
yeah
oh man
soldier boy
doesn't care
about protecting americans and he
probably never has
most heroes don't care about you
[Laughter]
yep
homelander is the worst of them oh my
god hashtag i believe starlight
he's done something to me
[Music]
i don't know what they're gonna do to me
for
telling the truth
but i'm going to keep doing it and i
should have done it sooner i'm sorry
oh
i'm not starlight anymore
my name is annie january
oh
and i [ __ ] quit
wow
what an ending
oh
here i was thinking we were just gonna
get a cool orgy episode
little did you know the real orgy was
the story sold along the way that was
such an intense episode
holy crap yeah
um damn i don't think there's a post
credits
okay
all right let's shitty chat it's chit
chat
well well well well i mean where do we
get
no time to digest let's just
just chat um before that
wow i got a lot of thoughts before that
a word from today's video sponsor
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video thank you
storyblocks
she was definitely not getting of time
no matter how much we import
it ain't gonna happen man ain't gonna
happen so thank you storybooks um thank
you for supporting the channel like that
anywho um
where to begin
where to begin
uh i guess with
freaking
uh wow a thick episode uh first that
comes to mind that homelander fight was
cool yeah there you go that's the first
thing we're gonna talk about i didn't
think we would get there in this episode
homelander versus soldier boy versus
huey versus butcher
i love the way that escalated you know
first just soldier boy then homelander
then butcher comes in and then huey
comes in
man he couldn't activate though we still
still don't have a good grasp of it
and uh of exactly how soldier boy's new
power set works but
might have discharged a little too early
apparently seems like it needs to build
up a little bit or needs the right
music or something but when we visited
crimson county he was able to do it
intentionally and he knows what he did
so it seems like that there's two
versions of that one is very intentional
and the other one is the blackout
version when he gets kind of lost like a
winter soldier type of
um mind experiment thingy and then he
does it and he's just like
he's even he was looking around he's
like what happened you know i know yeah
it was blacked out
yeah
um i like jensen knackles a lot i think
he's great as his character you know
he's just teetering on the right line
right line of that toxic
masculinity yeah
traditional american like just a guy
plucked out of a time period but i
what i think is cool of how they're
doing it because well there's a lot of
the soups in the show are very like
portrayed in a really nasty messed up
way
um
what you got with him is very different
in the sense of
he comes from a different time period
where beliefs
about
people
are very different and that's what's
applied here and he's being plucked out
of there put into this world and i like
that they're leading into a lot of those
things that are now considered very
problematic ways of thinking and that's
who he embodies because they haven't
directly portrayed him as a straight up
you know direct villain even though at
times he's does some things and says
some [ __ ] like when confronted with
mother's milk
about you know the family and he's like
which family was that you know like the
way he kind of shrugs it off but he
doesn't see he really seems like he
doesn't unlike homelander who kind of
embodies the whole thing of like i'm
different than the human race i'm
greater than he's got a godlike complex
soldier boy really seems like he doesn't
think he's a bad guy you know and at
least the way how jensen ackles portrays
him i really appreciate
um
the way that's all done there's always
like a tension in the room when he's
around like even when him and butcher
interact i'm always afraid that like
butcher's gonna say the wrong thing yes
take him off absolutely it's gonna lead
to some bad [ __ ] so i i really think
that what jensen apples is doing is um
excellent stuff and he
and and just there's something truly
delightful about seeing like the build
up of seeing soldier boy and homelanders
sharing the screen together and you got
two
very different american ideologies on
display here um where you have like the
one gruff and tough you know american
hero and then you have like the clean
cut cape wearing one yeah um and it is
uh in some ways like uh
i don't really know if i would kind of
compare it to like a batman v superman
or something like that
it's more of like a
no it's just his own thing you know it's
like you want to keep drawing the
analogies because in some ways it is a
little bit of like an iron man versus
captain america i mean i remember yeah i
remember just cap and bucky
it's probably the closest it is
to a civil war fight as it is but in
terms of like they're both not good
people
um but watching like the two time
periods clash is a fascinating
thing a magic well yeah it's like you
got one who's overtly
malicious and evil and the other one who
has
yeah some bad points of view and some
bad you know antiquated attitudes and a
certain
sense that he feels you know above
everybody you know in terms of he's not
really bothered when confronted with you
know mm's pastor or whatever else you
know he's very kind of uh
you know low he's just very chill about
that kind of stuff but in a very
different way that yeah it doesn't read
it's like he has that menace and i love
the different shades that jensen echoes
brings to him because it would be easy
to skate by on just like oh he's dean
he's back and and we love seeing him but
here it's like he's got such a presence
and such a sort of
he really does embody that sort of man
out of time all american quality and he
is a really fortunate as much as there
is like the obvious connections that got
him into the door for this there is like
a really nice parallel
to a chris evans type that he gets to
mirror and play off of and i think he is
a
wonderful casting choice for this and i
love watching
like the scenes that he had with huey
and then you know from from that all the
way to you know the chaos and the mayhem
you know it's been interesting to watch
this uneasy alliance form especially
because there is that quality where so
many of the soups are just outright
scummy in the worst way and this
obviously is an uneasy bond or an easy
partnership but
there's something he brings to it where
you're like well
of all these people to be partnered with
he does seem like one of the the least
overtly
horrible to deal with yeah it's like you
know the shoe has to drop but at the
same time you're like well
i guess if we had to have one of these
guys as an ally this guy's as good as
any
unfortunately
i don't know how the mother's milk
thinks he could possibly take him down
it's like all his method like he's just
so blinded with vengeance there's just
not a chance in hell he has and there's
nothing he's done at all i'm like maybe
that'll work
i know i almost wonder either there's
something else something to do with the
guns that he's packing that aren't
normal or or it's a death wish of his
own of sort of like i'm gonna go out
guns blazing and then if you know
probably likely
that's not going to do anything so then
i will you know be free of this pain and
rejoin my family basically
i really want to credit the writers
and the dire uh nellen nelson something
neil
i don't remember who directed it but i
really want to credit um
the the writers of this because they did
a
superb job this episode around like this
was
truly uh intense and and nelson craw
croc
and craig craig
um they did a seriously just a an
absolute wonderful job yeah because
they
you know when you're hearing hear
herogasm being built up cause i thought
hirogasm might be like crazier i thought
they would go even like way more
like balls to the wall a bunch of crazy
super hero stuff i mean there's only so
far you can go before you're just doing
something that's like x-rated
um
and
not even those boundaries matter anymore
on streaming tv it can though you can
still kind of it can go push to a
certain point i remember in the first
season there was one time where they
walk into the club and there is like
kind of a taste of what a herogasm could
be like when you are seeing a bunch of
superheroes at a club doing sexual
activities
and
here you know it's like it's it is like
feels like a full-on orgy uh but you
know like they didn't they didn't go as
far as i
was maybe a lot of us probably built up
in our heads of where they can go
with this um but i liked how it wasn't
about
that they didn't stop the episode to go
yeah which which they could have a
little bit of moments but in the
beginning yeah
yeah you set the scene
but yeah it's it's that thing of like we
didn't really get too distracted from
like the point of being there and i feel
like they could have taken five to ten
minutes break just to go crazy with
stuff but at the same time
yeah i don't feel like i was slighted
something no no by the way they handled
it so yeah it's it's funny it's like it
could have been more insane in some ways
you're like this is like a lot of orgy
scenes i've seen except for way more
close-ups on certain yeah and then a
couple of power moments yeah but i think
what they did
great
i think the environment created a sense
of uneasy tension yes totally so i
thought using herogasm as a way to
create
an unusual level of suspense and
um
was really cool like because it's such a
vulnerable position to be in it's an
exclusive event
and you know like when huey is walking
around
and you know like oh my god how is this
going to go down you know and like this
is
such an awkward
moment for for violence and the the
percolating suspense that
you know soldier boy is outside and he's
waiting to go in there
and you know murder a couple of people
i thought was
it was a really great groundwork to
create a stage for some [ __ ] to go down
you know so i thought that actually made
it more rewarding because yeah they had
their fun more in the beginning when mm
and starlight are first walking around
uh
look how deep
that's where he would go
you know he's sick best man loves well
the heart wants what it wants sick
bastard sick bastard
um
yeah his wife's not going to be happy
about that but i thought this was just a
very suspenseful episode like overall
and and with some great drama you know
the way they've been fleshing out
starlight's journey
of you know i've been saying it since
the trailers came out that this seems
like it's a breaking point season for
every character here
and i didn't really see that coming with
starlight to this extent
you know when she's uh talking with
newman you know that's a very
tension-filled scene as well like okay
now that seems like the moment when
newman is gonna partner up with
starlight and the boys but no she
doesn't go down that path either
uh and then her her um
it's like i like when they use
sounds like a weird statement i like
when they use the physicality of nudity
to be
a very vulnerable
emote like an emotionally vulnerable
position
so like huey and starlight having a nude
conversation out in the open where
everything is coming out
i think that's when a case of like oh
it's kind of funny when you first see
them there but really what's
making it even more vulnerable and hit
even harder is the fact that they are
both exposed fully in that moment and uh
i like i like the trajectory i think
they've done a really good job on
handling this is the most interesting i
think the romantic drama part of huey
and starlight has been in quite some
time
definitely yeah so yeah cause there's a
lot of tension uh to grab there but
freaking homelander why don't you
even touch on him yeah why don't you
talk about everything he was going
through here homelander with his green
goblins self-monologuing and everything
it's been fun to watch him yeah take the
reigns of vot and then have to deal with
all that and get that check back in
to see how important it is that part of
himself that still craves love and
acceptance and that is still human
because the further we get into
homelander as a character and the more
just unabashedly evil he becomes and the
less he's afraid to hide these parts of
himself you know it feels like we've
gotten really far away from that aspect
of the character and like you said
breaking points this season i could see
i mean he's already hinted at it but you
really do wonder that whole thing with
maeve at the beginning of the season
about you know release the tape if you
do fine i'll just kill everybody like
i was wondering how they would walk back
from that and i think they've done an
interesting job by giving him yeah all
this status and all his responsibilities
and
everyone else to look out for and
you know it's an interesting tension you
watch the scenes where he takes control
like on tv and stuff like that but in
this episode you know like ashley tells
him off at one point
uh even um and she doesn't no i say
train my bad uh but doesn't it doesn't
she
she tells off the tv host she tells off
the tv i thought she said something kind
of authoritative to homeland i must be
no i told off that she showed off the tv
host but yeah i mean just to watch him
panic and to watch him sort of squirm
and then to try and use these tv
appearances as you know his sort of
vie for power in everyone's eyes and
then to have all those things countered
then later on in the episode with this
physical convergence of
all these people who are out to get me
now you know yeah it's a nice
manifestation
of
you know all the enemies he's made on
this climb further and further past the
sun you know
oh yeah i mean i i like the way they
used because it was kind of mysterious
in how they painted
uh homelander realizing that could be
soldier boy in the last episode
and then to see what he's confronted
with here
because everything about what anthony
started along with the writers does in
this show is is so much of
the it's still the boy who was
experimented on
in this and his body uh this superhero
superhuman body
and
i really appreciate that nugget that
you know this is a
interesting trigger for him because
uh soldier boy was his hero growing up
and then
uh to be confronted with the fact that
he's back villainous he's now the leader
of vaught
like really really the the leader of
vaught not just the seven
what this could do image wise to him
what this does psychological wise to him
what this does to black noir
you know getting a bad like he has that
moment that's really funny and i like
when they bring those nuances in with
the humor you know when he
confides when when a homelander confides
in in black noir
says nothing and then homelanders like
i'm so glad you're here
literally does nothing
and then he feels abandoned by black
noir
all bringing up those childhood feelings
again within homelander i think
is they managed to construct a really
strong character like it's always been
character driven but they kept it really
character driven in an episode that i
think we all thought would just be balls
of the walls bunkers and it wasn't that
it it they had that but it was so
played so much on character you know
like you have soldier boy who's
um just completely lost and he's he's in
a world of like different belief systems
now and what it means to be a man is
what he's really focused on and then
also feeling hurt and betrayed
if everything with mm you know and i
like the parallel that they did because
in season two is when they were on the
road is when starlight's the first
character to point out that he has ocd
and then back on the road here is when
she finally gets the answer as to why he
has ocd
uh with the traumatic memory of the
night his uh family was killed by
soldier boy
i feel like there's something more to
that story that we're just like that
we're just not getting i mean i i don't
know
a train uh i would be thoroughly
satisfied if this is the episode he died
in i think this would be a great way to
end this character
i don't know for sure if he said i'm not
gonna be like oh what the [ __ ] was it
um
but you know you you see the that cause
that thing that ashley says to him like
yes hey trey makes good points about
black hawk blue hawk blue blue hawk i
think it's blue hawk because black hawk
is a dc character yeah i could say that
um blue hawk with um
everything he's confronting ashley about
is true
however what ashley says to him is also
very true that okay now that it's
something is personally affecting him
suddenly it's a problem you know and
that apology scene he has to huey it was
again like what they used as episode
fours to have everyone be so vulnerable
and his apology seemed really genuine to
the point where it was confused huey i
love the way they played that
really great and it's true he never did
apologize and
um
and uh
then when he does kill him you know i
think that i think just that would be a
great because it's not like he goes out
as like you know a a redemptive arc
but he did the things he felt were the
right things to do
he actually finally took action for some
motivation beyond his clout and his
status in the seven yeah because i don't
feel like the show is telling me to
forgive him
for the first stuff
but it he actually did something right
i know yeah i i wonder i mean it would
be definitely a very striking death for
him i wonder if there's still a story to
tell in terms of you know what happens
when you really can't physically sustain
your power anymore like this seems like
even if it's not his physical death this
may be the death of
a train and his abilities or something
like that like yeah i could see it
either way i would be very you know
satisfied with this but again i i feel
like there every time they give him a
really good scene i'm like yeah like
let's do more of this if they train well
i i think
they already
kind of did some of that with atrium and
he couldn't run in the first season i
think what you're talking about though
is what they're sort of doing already
with a chemical
of a character who's stripped over
powers and how does she adjust to life
i mean you get a different story with a
train
yeah uh a very different one but they
already they've already kind of explored
that with season one
it's like a healthy i guess i guess
because it's a health thing and they
they make that so specific i wonder but
you're also right like there are other
characters we can
explore similar things with
i'm curious i would see uh i think what
this season has done more than any other
season has put me on the edge and anyone
could die
i was like huey could die in that scene
right there if soldier away manages to
explode
um
[Music]
uh a train very well could be dead at
that moment i was like i don't think
kimiko is going to die but i feel like
frenchie is probably going to die
you know i'm so worried
i love their scenes but i'm so worried
for them i'm constantly worried french
is going to die this season it just
seems like it's headed that path
uh yeah starlight even like they could
kill star i really feel like they could
just kill off anyone right now other
than like butcher
now especially with starlight now the
gloves are off like part of me wants to
see that play
out longer but i i also
like this season feels really tight in
the sense that like you get
some really good emotion
mixed up with some really good tight
plotting and it feels like there's like
they've maximized all the room and space
that they're using and there's not
really anything that drags or leaves you
know like space that much so i do
wonder because they're good at like
hopping to the point like i never would
have expected this episode necessarily
to be the one where we actually get like
some of the things you would expect like
to be leading up to in a finale
um and so yeah i wonder if this season
could end with her death or something
like that
i think
well i think the the use of that
fight especially
there's only like two episodes left
right i think so
i think that fight in the finale what i
what i think
it does set the stage better because
even though we got that that early
then like episode eight what what they
what it does well is it with homelander
makes him
um
feel not invincible yeah he's properly
afraid now yeah he's truly shook up now
because he's probably angry and [ __ ]
but it's not only has a mess with his
psyche it's also
now made him feel weak
and that's
the main thing he's honed in on
is i am all powerful nothing and no one
can hurt me
and come to think of it after three
seasons this is the first time i've ever
i can recall being like damn homelander
almost died yeah you know homeland
didn't get out of there somebody would
have done something like that right take
three guys but still they got it done
almost yeah before no no one no one at
all has been able to do it you know um
yeah i loved it i loved it and and with
frenchie and chemical um
yeah that's just so heartbreaking i just
she's always so worried that
frenchie's always gonna die but you know
like with kim mcgo too you know
there's
she blames her powers but um
what was it called the liberation army
where she was raised
she's got a [ __ ] up upbringing and
it's like there's there's so much
i think so much of what this show
explores is how the the past of each of
these characters more than just frenchie
and kimiko
everyone's past really haunts them
and
especially with those two though because
they're the ones who it's like butcher
has everyone has mostly people have a
tragic past undoubtedly but i think with
butch i think with frenchie and kimiko
they really play it like a tragedy
whereas like butcher's like god he's a
badass confident guy says the c word all
the time
he's funny does kimiko and frenchy have
something in the
in a different way than say huey and
starlight because they're differently
positioned characters it feels like
frenchy and kimiko have the most
fragile and the most like
pertinent current right at the forefront
situation
that's yeah he could like you know he's
mortal she's got powers but only so much
and it really feels like they are the
ones in the most vulnerable position
yeah because butcher i mean yeah he's
got his i mean he's a lone wolf with a
team but you know he's got his own sort
of inner things to deal with and yeah
huey and starlight there's a whole other
power dynamic there whereas you know
kimiko and frenchie feel like they do
exist
on the street level
yeah and are sort of yeah
vulnerable especially to everything
going on and especially because of their
bond and that bond being so current
and them both being in a similar
position
of you know
not that this season they have to lay as
low but still like you know they're
they're not uh in the easiest position
out of everybody it seems like they're
kind of the hardest uh positioned in the
boys core group anyway well i think out
of them all especially in this season is
that they're the ones who are
they're the ones who most want to leave
and are the most taken advantage of
used
you know
it's like mm keeps making the choice to
go back like they make their choices and
[ __ ] but mm especially is a character
who's
constantly you know getting mad at
butcher and blaming him but he keeps
choosing to go back into all this
and i think he's doing a great job i'm
always i always have mad respect for
like the super buff actors who can like
be super vulnerable on camera because a
lot of times you're like ah you're hired
because you're like a buff charismatic
guy but you know when you can be that
grade a of an actor i'm always like hell
yeah
i love all of his scenes very impressive
yeah he's really likable and i like the
pairing of him and starlight a lot like
when that chemistry was really found in
season two i enjoy seeing carried over
here
i have no idea what's going to happen
it's been this whole season it's like i
don't know what's going on but
it's been a very thrilling ride that way
and uh a season this this ending with
starlight is a game changer could be
could could genuinely be a game changer
and it's knowing the trajectory of vaude
it's like oh you kill starlight then
blame her in some way or homelander just
embraces the side of the people who
truly embrace him because they keep
pulling out words that are so trumpy
you know when he's talking on stuff
um
so
i appreciate that and and i want them to
kind of lean into the corrupt side more
of the the liberal side the democratic
side with the newman who's obviously an
aoc representative in a lot of ways
you know not the not the same ethnicity
but it's so obvious that she's a play on
that you know yeah so uh i want to i
want to see that even though i like aoc
uh-huh sorry forever pissed off
um
yeah this is a damn good show this has
been a great season this has been a
fantastic season and i i think it's been
the most um hasn't been the funniest one
but it's been so emotional and taught
i love it it is
even the hair orgasm episode like not
that funny you know like there's some
laugh out gross gags and [ __ ] but it's
not the funniest season even this
episode i thought might be like the most
funny one but it really wasn't yeah it's
really precise like when they have humor
it lands and they do a lot of other
things that also land and so yeah i
think it's it's nice when a show like
this can do that where it's not like uh
it's not as funny so it's a little
uncomfortable now or something like that
like it still feels like the same world
but yeah
just slightly less cause for humor yeah
yeah even in your herogasm episode which
is pretty shocking all right guys what
did you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below thank you all
follow us on patreon thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
and last but not least let's do a page
fox
fox we're shouting on the boys because
the boys
only has one strong girl as a
protagonist well a few you know you
can't start life but i was thinking like
kimiko and i was like who's this strong
girl at our patreon who could kick an
ass it's definitely fox because fox is
like
fox is like a base people savage because
yeah fox is mean feral relentless sinks
her teeth into individuals
it's morbid just how
horrifying of a human being you are the
violence this is not gonna be a
complimentary shout out
you should be
arrested maybe thrown into an asylum or
something
to prevent you from more violent
criminal activity dark abyss in your
soul i really wanted to come in here and
be like you know you're like
you send us exercise equipment you're so
physically strong in all these things
you have great enthusiasm somehow we
went down this path and i'm sorry
or happened
you know what thank you for being part
of our patreon page for so long and
still sticking with us and being so
support i don't know why we just didn't
say that
i get uncomfortable when being honest
and then i say mean things i'm sorry
it's not you
it's john it's me i don't know how to
take responsibility for anything it's
okay and that's john's fault why i can't
yeah i'm so sorry guys i'm gonna figure
this out and make everything better
[Music]